War of the Worlds was directed by Steven
Spielberg and stars Tom Cruise welcome
back to my Tom Cruise series a very
brief series Jack Reacher never go back
is coming out very soon I thought it'd
be fun to talk about the Last Samurai
because that was also directed by Edward
Zwick as well as the upcoming Jack
Reacher film so it seemed like a perfect
thing to do and I thought hey why not
build up my catalogue of reviews and
talk about one more Tom Cruise film that
doesn't get talked about as much anymore
it's one of Spielberg's lesser films
it's definitely not one of his best
films but I don't consider it one of his
worst either it has some great things in
it and it has some terrible things in it
let's talk about both and if you've
never seen War of the Worlds this review
is gonna contain some spoilers you've
been warned I saw War of the Worlds back
in the day twice when it was in theaters
I saw it with a group of my friends and
their dad and then I took my mom to see
it the very same weekend it was a very
good theater movie in fact watching it
today at home on my surround sound with
my TV it was a very good blu-ray this is
a fantastic looking movie and a
fantastic sounding movie everything
about this movie technically is the
pinnacle of what movies can do in
regards to pure entertainment the way it
sounds the way it looks war the worlds
is fantastic something that Spielberg
did in the early 2000s with movies like
Minority Report which was his first
collaboration with Cruz and I think one
of his best and most underrated films as
well as in War of the Worlds is have
really overblown White's the white
levels in this movie are insane they're
overblown to shit and sometimes it can
be a little distracting but I think what
he was going for was sort of a more
retro appealing look and I guess it
works and you sort of get used to it
after a while but for those first few
scenes I'm like oh my god are they
standing in the limbo from the Harry
Potter universe like where the hell are
they something that Spielberg has had
for his entire career is an
awe-inspiring sense of spectacle and
that's something that he captured
amazing in the first two acts of War of
the Worlds the first act in particular
of this movie is like a plus material
it's so exciting and fun and something
that I really do love about this movie
is that similar to another alien
invasion film signs all of the action
that you might experience all of the
alien invasion stuff is only ever seen
when our characters are there to witness
it it doesn't cut away to other
countries we only
experience this invasion through this
family's perspective and that's
something that really is unique to this
type of genre and made this film special
like I said the first act especially is
basically flawless I have no problems
with it it's so exciting there's a
fantastic van scene on the highway
that's done in one take that's really
fun spielberg sense of awe-inspiring
spectacle does not waver for the first
half of this movie I also really like
their relationship between Tom Cruise as
the father character ray farrier and his
kids played by Dakota Fanning and Justin
Chatwin their mother's going away and he
has to watch them for a while nobody's
happy about this but shit goes down and
now they have to learn how to be a
family and that's one of the stronger
aspects of this movie is the family
dynamic because it's fun to watch these
characters learn how to work with one
another and can I just say that Justin
Chatwin has dragon ball toys on his
shelf he has a Crillon and an emperor
pilaf and since you know Dragonball
Evolution is my favorite movie of all
time I just thought I'd mention that so
those first two acts really good stuff
really fun movie and then something
happens it's almost like a longer way
either David kept the writer or Steven
Spielberg the director just decided we
want to get rid of the Robbie character
let's just have him grow this obsession
with joining the military and for
whatever reason Robbie really wants to
climb this hill and observe a war going
on with the aliens and cruise just kind
of has to let him because Dakota Fanning
is getting taken away by somebody it
just doesn't make any sense it's almost
like they were going for a metaphor of
having to eventually leave your children
behind or having to eventually accept
the fact that they've grown up and let
them leave the house or something
but it was done in the most strange way
and if that's really what they were
going for then I really don't get it
because it was out of left field and if
that's not what they were going for and
it's meant to be totally literal that
Justin Chatwin really wants to go
observe these deathly explosions with no
weaponry no training nothing he just
wants to go up this hill and die I guess
I really don't get it then the movie
definitely takes a step down were
introduced to Tim Robbins character who
is hiding in a basement and the scene is
so abrupt he's holding up a gun
over here over here and Tom Cruise and
Dakota Fanning run down into his cellar
and they're like thank you for taking us
in and it was like they just planned to
be there somehow or something it's
almost like they were like hey look we
know this scene is so random but look
it's Tim Robbins he's famous so forget
about the fact that this doesn't make
any sense either the movie drastically
changes here and there is a really good
scene in this basement very reminiscent
of the dinosaurs in the kitchen scene in
Jurassic Park with this strange alien
thing invading the area looking for them
it's very suspenseful and it's a very
good scene in fact that leads me to my
biggest issue with War of the Worlds
there are so many good scenes in this
movie there are a ton of great scenes
but sometimes it does feel like we are
watching a bunch of great scenes that
when viewed on their own are very good
but they just don't necessarily form a
cohesive whole there's definitely a
struggle with tone in this movie
especially in its third act that's where
things get really messy that's where
things change a lot
all of a sudden Robbie shows up
perfectly unharmed somehow because let's
hug it all feels so abrupt and the final
20 to 30 minutes of this movie really
skyrocket down in regards to quality
that the first half had but one of my
favorite parts of this movie is when Tom
Cruise makes a variation of the Macaulay
Culkin Home Alone face
[Music]
guys in the end war the world's is a
suitably entertaining movie with a great
first half in a last half that plummets
in quality it struggles with tone it
struggles with its character sometimes
but overall you can watch this movie for
its good performances it's great
direction but the storytelling could
have been a lot better I'm gonna give
War of the Worlds of B - guys look
forward to my review of Jack Reacher
never go back and if you haven't seen my
review for the Last Samurai I think
that's one of the most underrated movies
ever so definitely check that out you
guys are the best thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]